[Música]
y volvemos para hablar de economía con
nuestro periodista jorge hurtado jorge
buenos días para usted buenos días que
tal angela vamos a comenzar la jornada
hablando de los temas duros la cámara
baja de eeuu o promueve un plan para
ganarle a china y fabricar más chips de
qué se trata así es angelinos o no único
hace aproximadamente una semana la
comisión europea también anunció que va
a presentar en febrero un plan para
convertirse en pioneros en la producción
de chips ayer la cámara baja de eeuu
presentó un proyecto de ley que busca
mejorar la cadena de suministro y la
producción nacional de chips o
semiconductores según la propuesta
angela el gobierno invertirá a 52 mil
millones de dólares para subsidiar la
fabricación americana de chips
esenciales para la producción de
vehículos civiles y militares la
secretaria de comercio de eeuu alertó
sobre la alarmante falta de chips en el
país que podría obligar a cerrar
fábricas en caso de un repunte del cob y
19 según ella los fabricantes de
automóviles o aparatos médicos pasaron
de tener un inventario de microchips de
40 días para su fabricación a tenerlo
solamente por cinco días este problema
sera en 2022 según las autoridades la
asociación nacional de concesionarios de
automóviles afirma que la escasez de
chips redujo el inventario en los lotes
de los concesionarios en un 59% en
diciembre en comparación con el año
anterior y por qué son importante los
chips bueno se calcula que en cada
vehículo hay al menos más de 1500 de
ellos pues jorge le confía es una cosa y
es que yo soy de las usuarias que
todavía están esperando por causa de la
escasez de los chips pero bueno vamos a
cambiar de tema en el contexto en el que
ustedes y yo vivimos pareciera imposible
que un carro cueste más que una casa
pero en otras partes del mundo eso es
una realidad que es lo que sucede en el
siri lanka ha sido bueno hay como una
inflación que supera el 14 por ciento la
golpea de economía de esta isla vives
que haces de productos en los
supermercados debido a una prohibición
gubernamental a varias importaciones la
autoridades buscan priorizar la compra
de comida medicinas y combustible pero
al limitar la entrada de vehículos
nuevos los precios de los carros usados
están por las nubes una toyota land
cruiser de 5 años de uso cuesta más de
300 mil dólares el triple de lo que
costaba antes de la prohibición de
importaciones muchos restaurantes
también han cerrado por la falta de
suministros la agencia de calificación
advierten que sí blanca podría ir pronto
a la quiebra aunque el gobierno asegura
que cumplirá sus compromisos y
renegociar su deuda con china y en otros
temas el fondo monetario internacionales
rebajó su previsión de crecimiento
mundial en particular para américa
latina asia y bueno los grandes frenos
para este crecimiento son la inflación y
el cob y 19 sobre todo con los nuevos
brotes en 2021 la economía de américa
latina registró una tasa de crecimiento
del 68 % y para 2023 espera un
crecimiento del 2,6 por ciento según el
informe brasil crecerá apenas el 0
3% este año y méxico el 28 por ciento a
nivel mundial la variante omic aún frena
la recuperación sobre todo en las dos
mayores economías del mundo china y eeuu
el organismo recortó su previsión del
producto interno bruto mundial para 2022
al 4,4 por ciento escuchemos qué dicen
los directivos
y
hemos rebajado el crecimiento mundial al
4,4 este año lo que supone 0,5 puntos
porcentuales menos que nuestras cifras
de octubre la razón principal es la
importante reducción de los eeuu y de
china hay diferentes factores detrás de
ello como tal consideramos que tendrá un
impacto negativo en el primer trimestre
de este año pero para el conjunto del
año estimamos que su impacto será
bastante pequeño
y vamos ahora con los indicadores asia y
europa así que bueno comenzamos con
hacia las acciones asiáticas cerraron
mixtas entre las pérdidas de taiwán y
corea del sur y las ganancias de la
china continental y las tecnológicas de
hong kong antes de las vacaciones del
año nuevo lunar en europa las acciones
europeas se ampliaron sus ganancias
mientras los inversores se preparan para
cualquier endurecimiento de la política
monetaria por parte de la reserva
federal de eeuu
y para finalizar quiero pedirle que me
dé gusto como siempre con la cifra del
día bueno la cifra del día tiene que ver
con microsoft 51 mil 700 millones de
dólares eso reportó en ingresos en el
segundo trimestre y esto representa
aproximadamente un 20% más que el año
anterior pues surge el agradezco a
ustedes por toda la información y lo
invito para que se quede conmigo y vamos
con nuestro reportaje del día
[Música]